PROFESSOR: Good morning.
We're going to continue doing
perturbation theory today.
We've finished doing
non-degenerate perturbation
theory, and then turned to the
degenerate perturbation theory
as well.
We had computed already
the first order corrections
to the state, first order
corrections to the energy,
and second order
correction to the energy.
So here in this formulas
that I've written
are all the results
we have so far.
And a useful thing
is to ask yourself
whether you know what
every symbol here means.
This is the state who
change the deformation
of the original state n0
of the Hamiltonian H0.
We have the Hamiltonian
H of lambda,
which was equal to H0
plus lambda delta H.
And n0 was an eigenstate
of H0 with energy En0.
And we found that as
you turn on lambda,
lambda becomes non-zero.
The energies change.
The eigenstate changes.
And here is lambda, first
order in lambda, second order
in lambda.
We didn't compute the state
to second order in lambda.
Moreover, we have
the symbol delta Hkn
that was defined to
be the matrix element
on the unperturbed eigenstate
of the operator delta H. Well,
that's another symbol in here.
We are summing over all
states in the spectrum,
except for the state n here
because the denominator here
would give you a 0.
And this would be
problematic in general.
So that was what we derived.
And these are the
formulas we have.
It's worth making a
few remarks as to what
we see from these
formulas because they're
a little complicated.
And you may not have
immediate intuition about it.
So a few remarks.
And the first one--
in fact, both remarks
that I'm going
to make concern the behavior
of the energy as represented
by this formula.
First remark is that if you
were to look at the ground state
energy of the system, the
first two terms here, so for n
equals 0, if we call the
ground state by the label n
equals 0 for this
state n equals 0,
these first two terms on
the energy overestimate
the ground state energy.
They always give you more than
what the true ground state
energy is for any
value of lambda.
That is kind of plausible,
given that you see here
that for the ground state
energy, when n is equal to 0,
and it's the lowest
energy state,
these differences
are all positive.
All these states
have more energy.
Therefore, this
term is negative.
And the next correction
to order lambda square
tends to lower the energy
of the ground state.
So the claim is that the
first v lambda ground state
energy overestimate the
true ground state energy.
And so how do we see that?
So we consider E0, because
we're doing n equals 0.
This is the ground state.
We start labeling with
n equals 0 sometimes.
Plus lambda H00.
That is the order lambda
estimate for the ground state
energy.
The first term can be
viewed as the expectation
value of the original
Hamiltonian on the ground
state.
That is E0 because
this H0 and 0 is E00.
So this is E00.
Plus lambda.
I'm sorry here.
I made a little mistake.
That should be
delta H. Delta H00
plus lambda, the
expectation value of delta H
on the same state.
So these two things
together are nothing
but the expectation value on the
ground state of H0 plus lambda
delta H.
That's kind of nice.
Isn't it?
That these two terms
really are nothing else
but the expectation value on
the ground state of this thing
that we called H of lambda.
And now comes the
variational principal
that says that if you evaluate
the Hamiltonian on an arbitrary
state, the expectation value
of the Hamilton in an arbitrary
state, you get more energy
than the ground state
energy of the system.
You always get more.
And when you hit
the ground state,
you get the lowest value.
So look at that.
This is the Hamiltonian.
And this is the
unperturbed ground state.
This is not the
real ground state.
The real ground state is
what we're trying to find.
So this is like
saying, OK, you're
evaluating the exact Hamiltonian
on some arbitrary state.
Therefore, this is greater than
or equal to the true ground
state energy that we
would call E0 lambda.
True ground state energy.
Which in that notation,
indeed, is E0 lambda.
So that's a nice result.
And it matches with the idea
that for the ground state
the order lambda squared
correction is minus lambda
squared, the sum over k
different from 0 delta Hk0
squared over Ek minus E00.
And this thing, as we mentioned,
the numerator is positive.
The denominator is
positive because this
was the ground state.
And this is a
non-degenerate ground state.
And K, therefore, has
more energy here, Ek0.
So everything is positive.
So this is negative.
So actually here, there
is a generalization
of this observation.
And you can imagine that you
have now a particular state,
n here.
Then you have all these
states that are above
and all these states
that are below.
So let's look at the
second order correction
to the energy of the state En,
the second order correction.
The first order
correction shifts.
The energy is
proportional to delta Hmn.
But the second
order correction is
minus lambda squared, the
sum over k different from n.
So let's split it.
k greater than n.
And we'll write the same thing
Hkn squared over Ek0 minus En0.
And then I want to write the
other states, the states where
k is less than n.
But let me do one thing here.
On those states, I'll
switch the order of the sum.
I'll put En0, the order of the
sign in the denominator, Ek0,
and change the sign here.
So these two changes
of sign are correlated.
I changed the sign
in the denominator.
And I changed the sign in front.
And now, we see the following.
All these states that are
above n, k is greater than n.
This difference is positive.
This is manifestly positive.
This is negative.
So these states are kind
of pushing your state down.
The fact of this states on
top is a negative correction
are pushing the states down.
On the other hand,
the lower states,
the states with k less
than n, again, I've
ordered now convenient.
The other states k
now have less energy.
So this is positive.
This is positive.
So these states over here are
actually pushing that state up.
So the upper states
are pushing it down.
The lower states
are pushing it up.
This is usually referred
to as level repulsion.
The levels repel each other.
The upper states don't want the
state n to go close to them.
The lower states don't want
them to go close to them either.
So it's a nice dynamic
that helps you understand
what's going on here.
Another point we
want to make has
to do with the validity
of this expansion.
So in general, when you
have series expansions
the issues of
convergence are delicate.
So we can get a lot of insight
just by doing an example.
So let me talk about the
validity of the perturbation
series.
This is supposed to
give us some insight.
One thing we've said is
that we think delta H is
supposed to be smaller than h0.
Now, these are operators.
So the statement
that they're smaller
has to be made more precise.
What is the size of an operator?
And you could think,
well, we could
say the entries of
the matrix elements
should be much smaller.
And that is true,
but it's not enough.
For that, let's
consider an example.
So this will be a two by two
matrix Hamiltonian, in which
H of lambda will be given
by some H0 plus lambda v
hat, which will be E1
0 E2 0 plus lambda.
That v hat matrix will
be of the form v v star.
And must be her mission.
So v is a number.
v star is the complex conjugate.
These are the two energies,
because the Hamiltonian
is known.
Each time we talk about the
Hamiltonian that is known,
we write that there's
a diagonal matrix.
We're saying, yes, that
is the matrix element
of the Hamiltonian in the basis
of eigenstates, which we know.
So a known Hamiltonian you can
represent by a diagonal matrix.
So here is our whole
matrix H of lambda.
And you could say, all right,
our perturbation theory,
practically speaking,
is these formulas that
allow us to compute the
eigenvalues of this matrices,
which are of this
matrix, which is
the energies of the
system of the eigenstate
and compute the eigenstates.
For H0, these are
the eigenvalues.
And the eigenstates
are 1 0 and 0 1.
So perturbation
theory is really,
you can think in
terms of Hamiltonians,
but also you can think of
it in terms of matrices.
It's allowing you to find the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of this matrices.
So this is a two by two
matrix with numbers.
You know how to compute
the eigenvalues.
So I'll give you the answer.
The eigenvalues E plus
minus are E1 plus E2/2
plus minus E1 minus E2/2
times the square root of 1
plus lambda squared absolute
value of V2 squared E1
minus E2/2 squared.
Long formula.
That's it.
Those are the exact things.
If you wanted to see this as a
result in perturbation theory,
you would say, well,
lambda squared v squared
or lambda v is small.
And I'm going to think
of this term as small.
And I'm going to
expand the square root.
And if I expand
this square root,
I'm going to get
all kinds of terms
with different powers of lambda.
You can also see there that
there's no energy correction
linear in lambda.
Because when you expand 1
plus epsilon square root,
it's roughly 1 plus epsilon
over 2 plus dot, dot.
And therefore, when you
span the square root,
the first correction
is going to be
proportional to lambda squared.
And that actually
conforms to that
because the matrix elements
of the Hamiltonian delta
Hnn along the diagonals
for the perturbation are 0.
So there is no order
lambda correction.
So what do you do here then?
You must do this expansion.
And here, I write
the relevant series.
f of z, if you define
it, as 1 plus z squared
is equal 1 plus z squared over
2 minus z 4th over 8 plus z6/6.
And it's not that
simple after that.
Minus 5/128z to the 8
plus order z to the 10.
So that's this perturbative
series expansion
that you would use here.
And how good is the
convergence of this series?
Well, it's OK.
It's something that when
you study complex analysis
you see this function 1 plus
square root of z squared
has branch cuts at i and at
minus i in the complex plane,
in the z complex plane.
Those are the branch cuts.
These are the places where
this square root becomes 0.
And you have to deal with them.
And the function is
convergent only up to here.
There is a radius
of convergence.
A radius of convergence is 1.
You can try it with
Mathematica or with the program
and take 30 terms, 40 terms.
And you will see that as long
as you take a point z here,
it converges.
You take a point a little bit
out, it blows up the series.
So it has a radius
of convergence.
That's not so bad.
Radius of convergence is OK.
But basically, we need z to be
small, which corresponds here
to the statement that lambda v
z small for a fast convergence
corresponds to lambda
v absolute value
being smaller than E1 0 minus
E2 0 absolute value over 2.
Roughly smaller.
And now, we see that the thing
that matters for a perturbation
series to be good is also
that the perturbation be
small compared with
the energy differences.
Not just it should be
small, the perturbation.
It should be small compared
with the energy difference.
So if you have a Hamiltonian
with a state of energy 100
and a state of energy
101, you might say, well,
if I take a
perturbation of size two
or three, that's very small
compared to the energies.
But it's not been small compared
to the difference of energies.
And that can cause the
perturbation expansion
to go wrong.
So this gives you extra
insight that, in fact,
being a small perturbation
not only means small compared
to the energies, but
also small compared
with the energy differences.
Something that you
see here as well.
Energy differences are
controlling things.
And if the energy
differences are--
if the perturbation is not small
compared to energy differences,
then these ratios
can be rather large.
And the perturbation
terms are very large.
And nothing is very simple.
So that's what I wanted to
say about the convergence
of a perturbation expansion.
More rigorous
statements can be made,
but we're not going to
try to make them here.